traveling is a part of just the reason
why i liked coming into the business um
it was why we did that we in eastern
europe the one thing that the movie is
called focus right but in eastern europe
they kept saying us
[Applause]
what did we do yeah yeah you know i was
like well you know maybe one of y'all
not everybody
[Music]
because i started i started i told
myself i was doing all of my stunts i
was doing you know tom cruise that was
just hanging on the side of an airplane
yes at 50. yes i was like man i'm better
than tom cruise yeah
do it and i did like two stunts and i
was like i'm not better than that
is there anywhere in the world you can
go where
you aren't famous
um
that i i just haven't been there yet
but no it's really it was it's really
strange though it's like men in black is
everywhere on earth yeah and with these
ears you can't hide
no look good see because this this is
the problem
we're shooting this scene and i wanted i
wanted to have my uh my shirt on and
michael was like dude i'm gonna make you
a freaking movie star take your shirt
off
you know it was one of the iconic scenes
from that movie and to this day every
time i say michael bay he was like dude
i should be in for half
i made your career man
i had a little bit of a injury it's
called
dog jaw
i don't know do you have you ever i
don't think i have here
[Applause]
i remember i was in australia uh with
with arnold schwarzenegger and what the
well i wasn't with i didn't go to like
australia with arnie you know
i i was there i was there for a
promotional thing and he told me about
uh being a movie star he said
it's not just in america
you want to be famous it's everywhere in
the world
[Music]
you know that was actually pretty good
do the girls date when they're 14 hey
man
well i don't i don't know no not at 14 i
don't know what happened what would they
what did they do back in the 1800s
[Applause]
they flew you in you were a guest in
madame tutorials or something a wax book
review we saw a picture there's a
picture of you there yeah
that's creepy
you posted this photo or someone posted
this photo this is backstage just on set
oh man and you ran into the uh coming to
america
wesley and uh and eddie murphy that's
the black mount rushmore
[Laughter]
[Applause]
when i was young it was the pelvic lead
you know so this was how i used to take
pictures with all the fans and then i
felt like this wasn't you know yeah it's
not appropriate right no i feel
uncomfortable you feel uncomfortable
right
you feel good
you know i always always um you know
i've never like with focus this is the
first time like that it's like people
talking about sexy it feels weird
girl stop playing with me
that's all you want
thank you very much for that that's for
you man thank you very much
that was for you
that's so great uh i can't do that no no
you can no i can't do it and and
dave is in you we've known you there's a
negro inside of you dave
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wow
wow
that's the best news i've had in years
[Applause]
i gotta
i gotta run home and surprise the wife
you were the worst looking cast member
in i am legend it was me zombies
and a dog and a dog and i was the worst
look
all right you're the worst the king
the only reason
that you're saying that
is because you know i slept with your
mother
[Laughter]
i had a thing the other day like um
uh the perfect example it was it was uh
it was probably about three weeks ago
and i was driving and i realized i was
on e
and i you know i had been paying i don't
be paying attention but i was like
i was on e and i was like oh no so i was
about you know 30 minutes from my house
so i pulled into the gas station and i
didn't have my wallet oh and i was like
ah tragedy right yeah so i'm looking and
i'm looking i was like well like can i
call jada then she got to drive 30
minutes to come and i was like and i
looked over on the other side and i saw
a dude he was like 36 years old i was
like that dude's a fresh prince fan
[Laughter]
right you know
you can just spot him you can spot him
right you can spot him and i'm like you
know so i kind of rolled the window down
i was like
[Laughter]
you know after a couple minutes he was
like will oh yeah hey what's up man
what's up and he said hey man can i get
a picture i said yeah man i need about
ten dollars
it seems reasonable
and he was like really and he was like
really excited we took the selfie he let
me to ten dollars i was like give me a
number i'll send it back he's like dude
no way oh really no way that's yours
i was like
[Applause]
[Music]
all this uh footage some place a year
someplace and there's a guy and you uh
beat up a guy that was trying to hug you
i didn't beat up a guy
hoofed him
no no
what was the guy where were you first i
was in in moscow and we're doing this
what was the guy doing what's we're
doing an interview right right yeah and
he says man you know like uh you know
he's a reporter and he says i'm your
biggest fan can you you know can i have
a hug please so i go to give this joke a
hug and
he like tries to lean in to like kiss me
you know and that's first of all
how much it's just awkward dave
i i can see where it would be yeah but
what what kind of a journalist oh here's
my thing yeah you know i'm dan rather
i'm going to see if i can't kiss people
yeah you know but what is that i don't
know that's what they were saying they
were like oh no we're we're sorry you
know uh it's just his shtick you know
and i said well that's why his ass got
stuck yeah
you shocked your granny when you were
starting out with your music that i
shocked my granny yeah
god shot her shocked
after yeah
an accidental shooting in the sky
yeah i shot my granny
i want to be real hardcore hip hop
and that's another thing that i wanted
to talk to you about dave you know
because my son like he's he's he's
getting big and you know boys they get
that look in their eye you know it's
like it's like the little young lion
thing they get that look you sitting at
the dinner table and they kind of sizing
you up i just want to tell you be
careful man seriously
you know cause like my son i'm training
and i'm staying in shape for that day
you know but no i'm saying cause i fear
for you sometimes dave
because i'm so feeble well no no no
because you know it's like with your kid
cause you got a smart mouth so sometimes
you might say something
two sons and a daughter so i have you
know these you know little little
thundercats walking around my house now
you know so my sons but they're they're
skinny so you know they you know they
come up all the time and jayden just
looks like dad when am i gonna have that
you know i tell them i said boy this is
man meat okay
that's chicken breasts you're not gonna
you're not gonna you're not gonna have
this for a while so the girl a girl
asked jaden to to go on her prom oh yes
so yeah there he is
so jaden decided he was going to wear a
white batman suit
to her prom naturally sure yeah
so he informed her the night before at
which point she told her father and jade
and i get the emergency call and her
father's like hey guys um
let's i don't know but jayden uh just
informed mecca that he's going to wear a
batman suit to her prom and i just i'm
just you know calling you guys for a
little help here
and
jada said jada said sir listen i i am
really sorry but
here's the truth
just tell her to uninvite him
it was like
no problem with this family jaden is not
a prom date kind of kid
so jaden i tried to talk and i was like
jaden man it's a girls thing man you
can't can't wear a batman suit to the
girls
bro just like every father has said to
his son yeah right and he said dad i'll
compromise i'll wear a tie and he ended
up putting a tie well that's not over
the batman suit it's a formal batman
outfit so the next day he's like dad i
promise it will be the best time of her
life okay and the next day he comes in
and he shows me that he was trending
number one jaden smith with the batman
suit at the prom was trending number one
and number two was isis right
he said he looked at me he said dad i
agree with you something's wrong with
the world but it's not me
and i think the bigger point
is jaden beat isis
[Applause]